498 maternité sont répertoriés en france
c'est près de quatre fois moins que dans
les années 70 des fermetures successives
de maternité une tendance qui s'installe
dans l'hexagone dès 1972 à l'époque le
gouvernement souhaite renforcer la
sécurité des mères et des bébés le
décret jean hêches impose alors aux
établissements des normes d'encadrement
plus stricte et un nombre de quinze lits
minimum pour obtenir l'autorisation
d'exercer difficile donc pour les
petites structures de résister 1975 la
maternité d'auxonne dans les
départements de la côte-d'or faisait
partie des condamnés il ya une
législation hospitalière qu'il faut
quand même respecter et appliquer la
maternité dawson ne répond plus aux
normes des maternités tels qu'on les
conçoit actuellement un sort que des
centaines d'établissements connaîtront
ensuite des fermetures mais aussi des
regroupements de maternité observer
cette courbe en trois ans entre 1972 et
1975 le nombre de maternités était passé
de 1747 à 1369 une chute qui continuera
jusqu'au milieu des années 90 à cette
époque les petites maternités sont
toujours pointés du doigt pour simone
veil alors ministre de la santé
les mères et leurs bébés n'y était pas
en sécurité
elle préconisait la fermeture des
établissements avec moins de 300
naissances par an ce médecin dénoncé en
1994 une manoeuvre économique
alors je voudrais bien qu'on nous prouve
que nous sommes dangereux pousse des
petites maternités avant de nous fermer
quatre ans plus tard en 1998 le seuil
minimal d'activité pour une maternité
est officiellement fixée à 300
naissances par an un chiffre difficile à
atteindre en zone rurale et qui menaçait
une nouvelle fois les maternités de
proximité on sera obligé d'aller dans
des centres beaucoup plus important où
il y aura justement certain nombre
passer de chaleur avec avec le personnel
et puis cette confiance aussi dans les
années 2000 le nombre de maternités
continue de chuter et les petites
structures continuent de disparaître
aujourd'hui les établissements de moins
de 300 accouchements par an ne
représente plus que 5 % des maternités
loin très loin derrière les moyennes
les grosses structures face à cette
réalité des futures mamans manifestaient
leur colère en 2017
je vis à 2h de valence j'ai pas envie
d'accoucher au bord de la route ou à
mettre ma vie où la vie du bébé en
danger quoi tout simplement parce qu'on
a des choses qui existent déjà pourquoi
pourquoi le détruire quoi
une récente étude du service statistique
du ministère de la santé révèle que 167
1000 française vivant à plus de 45
minutes de voiture de la maternité la
plus proche
[Musique]